montréalais Montréal à l'aise vous
reconnaissez sans aucun doute ce sont
celui de la sirène qui rappelle aux
automobilistes de déplacer leur véhicule
ce soir dérangeant surtout quand c'est
vraiment tout le matin là un son qui
peut vite devenir un cauchemar pour les
parents de jeunes enfants ou pour les
employés en télétravail surtout dans les
métiers car faut que tu parles et tout
là te laisserais mes déménagements après
c'était l'autre sirène pour que les
autosent
plus j'entends des sirènes puis finir il
passe 15 minutes 20 minutes 30 minutes
plus tard c'est comme ça depuis je suis
tout petit il y aurait sûrement moyen de
faire autrement faire autrement la Ville
de Montréal y songe ayant reçu les
plainte au niveau du bruit on se demande
est-ce que c'est encore utile pour le
savoir un projet pilote a été lancé au
début de l'hiver on fait un dénombrement
avant de passage de la remorque et après
alors comme ça on va être capable de
savoir si l'effet de la sirène
a permis à des gens de déplacer leur
véhicule c'est très très bonne
initiative et peut-être une des
meilleures initiatives que la ville a
fait depuis ces dernières années car ce
sont contribue à la pollution sonore de
la ville et peut éventuellement devenir
nuisible les films médias il peut être
lié aux hormones de stress quand on est
stressé par un bruit on génère des
hormones de stress qui vont avoir un
impact sur notre santé et ça c'est
quelque chose de très important à partir
du moment où on sait que ce bruit là
pour être éviter il aura tendance à nous
déranger beaucoup plus
[Musique]
mais la ville doit jongler avec un
impératif s'assurer que la voix soit
libre pour le déneigement car chaque
véhicule qui doit être remarqué retarde
considérablement
l'opérations qu'on doit remorquer ça
représente somme toute 50 véhicules à
l'heure à chaque fois qu'on doit
déplacer un véhicule ça va nous ralentir
de 5 à 10 minutes et c'est pourquoi la
réussite d'une opération des neigements
demande la collaboration de tout un
chacun reste maintenant à voir s'il est
possible d'y arriver en délaissant la
fameuse sirène ici qui me permettra au
Canada Montréal